- Eli, I’m scared.
- It’s going to be OK.
Saquon, I’m scared.
- ♪OOOOOOOOH. THURSDAY NIGHT.♪
- SOMEONE MUST MAKE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
SO, LET’S DECIDE WHO’S PLAYING ON
THURSDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL!
BUT THAT’S ONLY A FOUR-DAY
TURNAROUND FOR INJURIES.
- ♪Waiting half a week for Thursday night.♪
- This week’s game
will be streamed exclusively on Myspace
with our worst broadcast team.
- So the little guy passes to another guy,
and I don’t know, I give up.
- WE VOLUNTEER AS PRIME TIME.
- SIR, NO!
- We can’t handle the spotlight!
- QUIET, QUARTERBACKS!
- THE FIRST TEAM SELECTED IS…
THE DOLPHINS!
- Hey, Rog,
Coach put our name in like a thousand times.
- WAIT, WAIT, WHO'S TRYING TO SABOTAGE THE—
HEY, MAN, WHOSE BUCKET IS THIS?!?!
- Fine...
The Chiefs.
- ONLY FOUR DAYS TO GAME-PLAN?!?!
- All right, how about the Bears? OK?
- Uh, we already doink it.
I mean, we already did it.
Matt, Parkey can’t hurt you anymore.
- NO, NO, NO.
WE MUST GIVE THE FOOTBALL GODS
AN UNEXCITING MATCHUP.
- IT IS WRITTEN.
TITANS-JAGS.
THE ULTIMATE THURSDAY GAME.
- Yeehaw! I’ll dance on a Thursday!
- HEY, YOU.
YEAH, ALL FREAKIN’ HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOU
Flipping listen to me.
I’m P.O.’d about the M.F.ing lurkers watching our B.S.
So subscribe to this G.D. channel or G.T. the Fluff O.
DADDY SAYS SUBSCRIBE.